[Music]
hi this is Jeff Stone with great race
and we're here today with another
segment of our how-to videos and today
we're going to talk in a little bit more
detail about how to fill out a time
delay form now inevitably on the great
race you're going to get stopped at some
point in the 2400 miles in nine days by
a train a tractor possibly a school bus
or construction now when that happens
first of all Don't
Panic you may be new to the great race
and and we do talk a lot about staying
on course and staying on time and we do
want you to stay on time that's the
whole idea of the of the game but if
something happens let's call it a a
train first thing you do is pull is stop
the vehicle and start your
stopwatch at that point
relax it's going to be a few minutes
before the train passes yes you're
getting behind one minute two minutes
maybe even three minutes by a train
don't worry about it that is what the
time delay is for when you turn in your
time delay it goes back and calculates
as if the event had never happened if if
you do it correctly
and it your score will be just as it was
before now I'm not going to get into a
lot of specifics about um uh starting
the stopwatch halfway down and halfway
up at your speeds the simplest way is to
um add back in the speed the a stop and
go uh time to the speed you're doing
when you stop but if you start your
stopwatch when the vehicle starts or
stops and you start it back when the
vehicle starts moving let's say it was 3
minutes and 47 seconds you stopped by
that
train the first thing you need to do
after you get going again is to get in a
multiple of 10 time delays can be turned
in in a multip any multiples of 10
seconds so 3 minutes and 47 seconds is
not a multiple of 10 seconds so first
thing you want to do is make up 7
Seconds to get time to lay down to 3
minutes and 40 seconds that is a
multiple of 10 seconds now we want you
to make up that time if possible and if
sa if if it's safe you want to be safe
at all times but let's say the
checkpoint is
coming you still have that 3 minute and
40 second time delay don't worry go
through the checkpoint as as
usual mark down what
time or what instruction number that
time delay is
for and on the form you will take this
form and the first thing you do is write
down your car number it says car number
and we're going to say we're car number
99 and let's call this stage two that's
what day of the rally it is so if this
is the second day that's stage two and
then the leg number now the leg number
is the the number of checkpoints you've
passed if we've passed checkpoint number
four we're now working on leg number
five and the most important part is the
instruction numbers that the event
happened let's say we got stopped at the
train between instructions number 102
and 103 and you put that down and then
you put down 3 minutes 40 seconds okay
then there's a place to write the
description we were stopped by a train
that actually suffices on something like
that if it was a school bus you just put
it was a school bus if it was a uh giant
combine in the road and a lot of times
out in the midwest we will see those put
stopped by a giant combine for whatever
amount of time you then sign it uh
there's also a place if other people
were stopped by the train car number two
ahead of us and car number eight behind
us we're also there there's a place to
write that down now if this is before
lunch you will turn it in at lunch time
there'll be somebody there to ask you if
you have time delay in case you forget
or at the Finish Line each night the
first thing they'll ask you is do you
have a time delay that's where you turn
that in I already have it filled out
with the all the information already
done so that you don't have to uh keep a
delay there at the at the Finish
Line very simple Don't Panic start your
stopwatch when the car stops start your
stopwatch again when it start car starts
moving if you add in your stop and go
times off your performance chart to that
number you will have your time delay get
it down to a multiple of 10 and you'll
be good to go if you have any more
questions on this it's not as hard as it
seems but if you have any more questions
you can call me at 800
98972 23 or email me at Jeff great
race.com we be glad to try to help you
any way we
[Music]
can